why have you been able to create the
roles and the projects you want in
Atlanta but not so much in Hollywood
price
[Laughter]
I think that
so in Hollywood and I noticed it even
when I flew in
it's like there's there's this go go go
there's this hustle hustle hustle
struggle struggle struggle survive
survive survive you feel that energy
here
and in Atlanta it's a lot easier to get
locations it's a lot easier to get
collaborative people
because
a lot of times it's just the effort the
aligned effort I don't even call work
work anymore it's just a lined effort
right so when you have that aligned
effort with multiple people
you're able to get something that's a
lot more magical a lot of times you hear
from people that say Hey if you're gonna
make an indie film make it in one
location right
and I'm completely against that and the
only reason why I'm against that is
because you still have to make the film
interesting to the viewer and if you
only have one location there's only so
much you can do not to say that there
hasn't been successful films in one
location but when you're an indie
filmmaker you're trying to maximize
production value and how can you
maximize production value on a stringed
budget
in Georgia you're able to get these
locations that you would never unless
you knew the owner of this place or
something or he was an uncle you would
never be able to get
so that is probably why it's so much
easier to create in Georgia
and it's cleaner there too isn't it like
it looks from from the stuff that I was
seeing on your channel like it just
looks so clean and all the places look
so nice like San Fernando Valley for
anyone who hasn't come here you really
feel the struggle here yeah and and
that's just you know minutes away from
Hollywood but there is that's funny as
an outsider for just a little bit seeing
that perspective because when you live
in it day in and day out you don't even
realize it yeah absolutely and the thing
is it's not to say that Atlanta the city
doesn't have its struggle because it
does but you know the the state of
Georgia is very family oriented small
businesses right so if you kind of if
you're into those two things Georgia
will be great now you're going to have
your little pockets that's real country
but if you're not into those pockets and
you're kind of like in the Metro areas
and stuff it's it's a beautiful place to
live
but there's still
it's a lot easier for you to get your
project done in Georgia and I would
assume for any filmmaker in Kansas Idaho
Chicago any place in Georgia outside of
LA and New York I would assume it's so
much easier for you to use what you have
use the places that you visit frequently
where people know your face and if
you're able to write your story around
that kind of stuff because if you're an
indie filmmaker and your thought process
I know my thought process is I'm not
looking to sell this to somebody to hope
that somebody else gives them a yes to
then hope that somebody else gives them
a yes to go make this project I write
within what I know that I can accomplish
to go shoot
so I don't have a backlog of 10 15 20
scripts I write shoot write shoot write
shoot
that if you're in another state and
you're like man I need to get to
Hollywood or I need to get to Atlanta I
want to get into the industry
you can start the industry where you are
because all it takes
is One Financial successful hit and the
reason why I say Financial
is because nobody cares how good your
movie is if it's not financially
successful because it's a business so if
you can create something that's
financially successful
and get a return
Where You Are
then you can create
your own solar system
of Hollywood Where You Are
for my films I use the same actors the
same people they don't even audition
anymore
for all of the roles I'll call them up
hey do you want to play this role yeah
okay cool we're gonna do it and then
that's I I really wanted the the Adam
Sandler
thing I really wanted to to have this
core group of actors that we become
family and we work on all of the same
projects together because one thing that
I know about Indie filmmaking
and this is really advice to any
filmmaker
energy
cohesive energy amongst people
is a lot more valuable and you'll get a
better product than having somebody
that's extremely talented could be the
best actor best writer best anything
best director
but if their energy is not cohesive with
the rest of the crew and cast
then one drop of toxic and you know a
gallon of water it's still poisonous
so
energy is important why did you schedule
the production on Sundays
so
I knew that
I was free
and I was able to focus on weekends to
shoot and I knew that majority of the
time
actors aren't doing anything on weekends
so I thought to myself hey we can either
make movies on weekends while we're
watching Netflix from our couch
or
we can do nothing and watch Netflix from
our couch so that's why you know
weekends is the most beneficial because
I work like everyone else we work during
the week you know we have rent to pay
and bills to pay but on the weekends
it's like
that's fun time you can either relax or
create and I think a lot of actors can
agree with this
you feel alive like I know for me I I
come alive when I'm filming when I'm on
set like it it's a feeling like no other
it's almost like a
I don't want to say hi because I don't
do drugs and I never have but it's
almost like a high I would say for the
lack of better words
I come alive when I perform
and I know other actors for this way
because you can see the Sparkle turn on
when it's like action you see the
sparkle when they see themselves on the
screen you see the sparkle
you're able to take the audience to
another world right and
it's so important because majority of
the actors on my films
first time actors maybe they've done
like a student film or a short film but
they're not they don't have these heavy
credits you have like one or two that
have a lot of credits but for a lot of
them it's their first time
so by being able to give them that
experience to let them know like hey you
already did one movie you can audition
and you can do other movies and you can
make it happen because you've already
did it
you have you're boosting other people as
well you're giving other people
opportunities to Showcase what they
really want to do and you're letting
them know like hey this is a safe space
you have the creative freedom to talk
yeah the creative freedom to say
whatever you want you have the creative
freedom to like a line or not like a
line and change it and play it how you
want to play it you have that freedom
you don't have to feel nervous
um and if you look on the films a lot of
times you're you're not really able to
tell that it's a first time actor or a
second time actor because
that comfortability right acting is
about being comfortable just when
there's action you're comfortable and
you're going to get two different
responses from actors one that's not
comfortable
they're gonna rush through their lines
oh my God what is that huh what
comfortable actor oh my God
what is that
okay that's great I like that tape right
because
that's what we were trying to convey
if you can allow someone to be
comfortable you're able to get a better
performance and I think that
by a shooting on the weekends
you're already relaxed and then by
shooting with the same people same
actors same crew there's familiarity
there's no pressure
by you having the freedom as a Creator
or a creative to do whatever you want
now you know like hey it doesn't matter
if you mess up lines
I will sometimes purposely mess up lines
to let everyone know like it's okay
we're just gonna push record again and
we're gonna go
and
I think that
by shooting on weekends you're able to
get a lot more collaborative people on
board with your projects
because they're not doing anything on
those weekends anyways for the most part
plus two it's in Atlanta and I know
there's a lot of Productions but not as
much as La so do you think people feel
too this an excitement that they're part
of a Film Production
yeah absolutely I mean
you know how do you climb the stairs
without taking steps
right you have to take steps and
once you're able to get your feet wet
you're able to swim in the pool
and it's important to join your theater
group your do student films short films
commercials because you're getting
experience points like a lot of times
I think people see people on TV and they
say
I can do that it's no problem that's
easy
for some people oh it is easy for some
people but for most people
you know how much work it takes just to
be comfortable in front of the camera
and have a hundred people looking at you
sometimes it's not about you being able
to do it sometimes it's about you
trusting in yourself enough and being
comfortable enough to do it
and sometimes that's the barrier so I
used to be really bad at auditions even
though I would get a lot of callbacks
and stuff I used to just not perform as
good as I could but anytime I booked a
film or a commercial or anything
I did fantastic when it was go time
and I don't know what that circuitry was
if I could if I could take that go time
and put it in auditions I probably would
book a lot more
but for some reason I didn't view the
audition
as the job
and I think if you view the audition as
the job
you'll win more
and you'll do more
as a creative